welcome back
i'm steve brunton and i'm going to go a
little bit deeper today
into this research topic of using using
machine learning for
fluid mechanics so this is a topic
that's very near and dear to my heart
is kind of adapting modern methods in
machine learning to solve really really
hard and important problems in
engineering
especially in fluid mechanics which
again we live in a fluid fluids are all
around us
we don't even think about it often but
we drive and we fly
through fluids we breathe fluids machine
learning has a lot to offer
in this field and so we've seen before
that there are these incredible advances
in
machine learning for image sciences
especially so image
image sciences is one of the most
developed and advanced fields of machine
learning
and you can oftentimes apply these
techniques
to fluid mechanics to fluid flow fields
if you think of the
the flow field or your fluid as a
picture
and if you think of how that flow field
evolves in time as a movie
then you can carry a lot of these
machine learning techniques over
directly
just by thinking of your flow field as
an image okay
and this is just a really great uh
simulation run by petros varelas
where where he was able to kind of add
life to van gogh's starry night um there
will be a link to this
this video where you should you should
go check it out this is super cool you
can even
uh it's interactive so you can play with
this and push on the fluid
and do all kinds of fun fun things okay
so again
if you think of your flow as an image or
an image sequence
tons of cool stuff you can do so i'm
going to dig a little bit deeper
into what's possible and just a couple
of vignettes of thinking of flow fields
as images and again just to point out
a lot of this is following this recent
review paper machine learning for fluid
mechanics uh by myself barrett noack and
petrus kumasakis
this came out in 2020 and you can
download a free copy on the archive at
this link below
okay so one of the major major ideas
in all of both fluid mechanics data
driven fluid mechanics
and in machine learning research is that
even in very complex systems
patterns exist even if i had a megapixel
image of a human
face all of those million pieces of
information are not actually important
necessarily
there are dominant patterns that define
human faces and there are dominant
patterns that define flow fields
this is actually i'm going to take a
little tangent because this is super
interesting
in 1987 cyrovich wrote two papers that
changed the world
one of them was his famous eigenfaces
paper
where he took a library a large library
of
images of human faces and essentially
took the principal components or the
singular value decomposition of that
library
to get the eigenfaces so he was able to
pull
these low dimensional patterns outside
of lots of images of human faces
that changed image sciences in that same
year he applied the same technique
to flow field images he took movies of
flow fields and showed that if you take
their singular value decomposition
you can pull out eigenflow fields and
extract these dominant patterns
and that was actually one of kind of the
early papers in
imaging sciences and pattern extraction
for
for images where machine learning has
grown up out of
and so i think that's really interesting
that we're coming full circle a lot of
machine learning research came out of
fluid mechanics like the eigenfaces
example
and now they're coming back and giving
us even more powerful tools
to analyze these systems good so
again the proper orthogonal
decomposition and i'm going to go
through
some of the material i talked about very
very rapidly in the overview
and i'm going to go into a little bit
more depth here so in the pod the proper
orthogonal decomposition or the
principal components analysis
you're able to take a very complex flow
field a movie
or image sequence of a very complex flow
field maybe this has a million degrees
of freedom maybe it's a megapixel image
or i had to run a simulation with a
million degrees of freedom to get this
but you can tell that this is actually
quite simple just like the human face
all of those million pixels aren't
important there's a very regular
pattern emerging here and you can
extract these patterns using very simple
tools in linear algebra
so for example you can subtract off the
average flow or the mean flow which
looks like this
and then you can run a singular value
decomposition on the remaining image
sequence
to get this pod expansion okay and what
that does
is that writes this flow field it's up
here in the summation
it writes my flow field which is a
function of space and time
as my average field plus a summation of
maybe the first
10 of these eigenflow fields and these
eigenflow fields are static in space
and it's just the mixture of these that
changes in time these uh
a sub k of t's the mixture of these
eigenflow fields changes in time
and you add up that mixture at time t
and you get this flow field at time t
really beautiful idea this has been
around for you know for
not not the svd approach but this basic
uh
pod and fluids has been around for 50
years and it's a
cornerstone of how we analyze and work
with with high dimensional fluids as you
run this
decomposition into into this coordinate
system
now i'll point out this looks a lot like
a fourier decomposition
a separation of variables a space-time
separation of variables which is how we
uh we solve lots of partial differential
equations using the fourier transform
this is a data-driven generalization of
the fourier transform
that satisfies these particular boundary
conditions and is generated from
physical data from an actual flow
simulation
now again fast forward into kind of the
modern
era and it's been shown that you can
rewrite that proper orthogonal
decomposition or that principle
components analysis
as a neural network so you can write it
as this very simple
uh shallow neural network with one
hidden layer in the middle
only linear activation units and what
you have is your high dimensional flow
field
as an input the information is
compressed into this middle layer this
latent space
and then the decoder reconstructs the
full flow field image
and so by training the neural network to
basically minimize the loss between the
reconstructed image and the original
image
and by forcing as few variables as
possible in the middle layer
this is an information compression or an
information bottleneck
that distills the most important fluid
coherent structures that you need
to add up and reconstruct the full flow
image okay
so it's been known for a long time that
you can solve that problem using neural
networks
but what's really cool is that now you
can use a deep autoencoder
with many many many hidden layers and
non-linear activation functions to do
the same
task just better so oftentimes you can
get enhanced compression or
fewer latent variables in the middle
if you use this deep non-linear
autoencoder and you can get
better coordinate representations of
your flow field and that means
you get more compression and you get
simpler representations to work with
for all downstream tasks now i'll point
out
that um milano and kumitsakis in 2002
were the first ones to use this deep
autoencoder in the field of fluid
mechanics
and that again is really ahead of its
time like now
15 20 years later people are are
starting to really start using these
deep auto encoders in full force and
fluids
they were doing this way before it was
kind of common
or or standard practice okay
good so once you have that that notion
that low dimensional patterns exist in
your data
you can do a lot of things like
robustify the extraction of these
patterns if you have noisy data or
corrupt data
or data with outliers and so that's this
idea of robust pod or robust pca this is
kind of a riff on
an emerging field of robust statistics
that we're applying to fluid mechanics
and in particular we're applying this to
fluid mechanic systems like these
experimental measurements of a
of a flow field using laser sheets this
is particle image velocimetry
it's a technique where you can measure
kind of the flow velocity field
uh non-invasively by shining a laser
sheet through
the flow and taking high speed images of
how particles in that laser sheet move
okay but as neat as this technique is
and it's incredibly cool
the movies that you get the flow field
reconstructions that you get from this
method are often highly noisy
and have this kind of salt and pepper tv
static looking noise on top
because you're always pushing the limits
of your measurement system you always
want higher resolution and faster
over a larger window and so you're
always spreading your laser sheet thin
and you're always pushing the limits of
what your camera can measure okay that's
just human natures you want to get the
most you possibly can
but sometimes that means that your data
can can have this kind of these
artifacts
uh and so in the field of image sciences
again
uh this great paper by candes and
co-authors showed
that if you have data like the
eigenfaces data like this massive
library of human faces
here there's 36 people and for each
person there are 64 images
in different lighting conditions if you
have this huge statistical database of
human faces
you can extract what are the common
patterns and features that all humans
share in common
and so if i have this image here of a
person with this kind of fake phony
mustache added
this algorithm can subtract off that
mustache and tell us what was
what was underneath the mustache really
cool technology
we are going to apply this to fluid
flows again if you think of flow fields
as images that have patterns just like
faces do
we're going to be able to do the same
thing we can do here and we're going to
subtract off those artifacts and those
big
salt and pepper noise from our
experimental measurements
so this is really great work uh by
isabelle shirl a phd
student working with brian palaji and me
and what she did was adapt this
candes uh robust principal components
algorithm
to flow field estimation okay so uh i'm
not going to get into the details of the
optimization the
big picture is that you can write this
as a really really hard optimization
problem
and then you can relax it into an
optimization problem that you can solve
using data and what she does is she
takes this
um this flow field that we know has low
dimensional patterns
but she's corrupted randomly many many
of the pixels with salt and pepper noise
so essentially just blacking out lots of
those pixels randomly
but running this this machine learning
optimization again
on this data knowing that it has
patterns it's possible to
separate out the low rank structures the
patterns that we care about
from all of the kind of corruption and
crud that's on the data
in that s matrix and this is really
really useful this means that even if
you have noisy or corrupt
data with lots of outliers you can split
it into the patterns you care about
and you can discard kind of this this s
matrix
good and once you have this low rank
matrix you can get
much much better approximations of those
pod modes
kind of these are the true modes here
this is what would happen if you did pod
on this noisy data
and this is what you get when you run
pod on isabelle's
filtered low rank matrix l so you get
much much better
modes and patterns and when you build
dynamical systems models to predict how
this movie evolves in time you get much
much better models we know that all
these eigenvalues should live on this
unit circle because it's a periodic flow
and after filtering we get a really
really good dynamic mode decomposition
model where all the eigenvalues or most
of the eigenvalues are on the unit
circle
but if you naively applied that
algorithm directly to this data
you would get a terrible representation
of the dynamics almost none of the
eigenvalues are on this unit circle
where they should be
okay so it goes to show that if you
treat this like an image sequence
you can use these really powerful
techniques for robust statistics
to get better flow field estimates and
better models okay good
so in addition you can again use these
image
techniques like super resolution for uh
for flow field
enhancement okay and i've talked a
little bit about this before
i'm going to talk about it again this is
one of my favorite examples because it
really highlights some of the challenges
we have
uh in fluid mechanics as it compares to
image sciences
okay so again uh super resolution is
this idea that you can take a low res
image and fill in the details get this
really really high fidelity beautiful
crisp image
if you have an extensive offline library
of high resolution images to train
on to learn the statistics of what in
this case a human eye
looks like okay so it's also possible to
apply this in the field of fluid
mechanics and i want to point out
there are tons of groups working on this
i am showing you one paper
uh from ben erickson and uh i was a
co-author on this paper
um this is just one example ben's
example
uh i know sam tyra and others are doing
super resolution and
lots of other groups okay so full
disclosure
but in this paper what ben did was
essentially built this shallow decoder
so one of the things he wanted to show
is that you didn't need
a super deep neural network you could do
this with a shallow decoder
that would allow you to take a few
sensor measurements or a low resolution
image
and kind of paint in or fill in all of
the details in a high resolution image
again if you had this massive training
set
of high resolution flow fields to train
on so this data is from the johns
hopkins turbulence database it's a
fantastic resource
where you can download tons and tons and
tons of high fidelity
data from fluid simulations a variety of
fluid simulations
huge service to the field uh is the
johns hopkins turbulence data set
and so what ben showed was that
essentially
you can get this really really nice
super resolution
uh reconstruction of your image even
from this very low resolution down
sample
image if you run this as an
interpolation
and this is this is what's i think
really important is in machine learning
you know that when you train your
algorithms you take your your data set
and often what you do is you kind of
randomly pull eighty percent of that
data set to train your model
and then you test it on the remaining
twenty percent that's and then you would
randomly reshuffle and do it again and
again and again
in a cross validation okay and if we do
that
we actually get excellent excellent
reconstruction super resolution
reconstructions
and remember this came from a movie
these image is our image sequences from
a movie
and so if i look down here this kind of
standard cross-validation approach
is essentially an interpolation problem
so these uh what we do is we train on
these dark columns
and we test on these bright blue columns
and so this bright blue column here is
sandwiched right between two images
in my training data so in some sense
we're able to
do this reconstruction because it's an
interpolation
of things i've already seen in the flow
field okay
when we do an extrapolation task things
get much much trickier and this is
actually more realistic for lots of flow
scenarios
maybe i have this movie and i train for
the first eighty percent of it in time
and then i try to predict or do the
super resolution on the next twenty
percent in time
so i'm not randomly sampling
in time but i only sample the first 80
this is what you would actually want to
do if you for example wanted to build a
model
uh of the climate or the weather or the
flow in the ocean as you do
historical data and then you would start
applying that model
in the future starting at time now okay
and that's a much harder problem that's
an extrapolation problem so the farther
you get from
where your training data ends if you
start you know the first snapshot right
after
you get beautiful reconstruction but as
you go farther and farther
in time away from where you had training
data your estimation degrades
and so extrapolation is super hard you
have to do a lot more you have to build
in physics if you want to be able to do
a proper extrapolation
task at least in a lot of cases and in
image sciences i want to point out
when you train uh like a classifier or
something
a super resolution on imagenet the
assumption
is is that that training data has
pretty much everything you'd ever want
to classify in it
so it already contains everything that
you ever would want to to reconstruct or
classify
and the assumption is that all future
tasks are going to be an interpolation
of that training data that is not the
case in lots of fluid systems it is not
possible to just interpolate uh these
flow fields
in the future and that's one of the key
distinctions is that these flow fields
these turbulent flow fields often have
many many ranges of scale separation in
space
and in time that make it very hard to
generalize to future scenarios
and so this is kind of a an example of
lots of flow fields this is a great
paper by
by jared callahan you can read it about
it in physical review fluids or on the
archive
and what he looked at was this range of
flow fields of varying complexity
and kind of how a training data set
would generalize to a testing data set
so often times we build our models and
demonstrate our algorithms on this
really simple flow past a cylinder
in a lot of ways i think what jared
showed is that that's
far too simple of an example and when
you start using those ideas in these
really complicated flow fields like the
the flow in the gulf of mexico or this
spatially evolving mixing layer flow you
really have a hard time
getting your training data to have
enough kind of richness of data
that it will generalize to the future
and so
you can actually kind of quantify this
at least using the singular value
decomposition
how much training data you need before
you get a certain
accuracy kind of reconstruction in the
future for an extrapolation task
and essentially what what he shows here
is that for some of these flow fields
you might need tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of snapshots
before you reach this kind of
statistical stationarity where you get
an interpolation problem instead of an
extrapolation problem
and these are not actually even that
complex of flow fields right like
industrial flow fields flow past a
submarine or a boeing jet
are going to be exceedingly high
dimensional and they're going to be even
harder to characterize in the
statistically stationary way
okay good so i think that's really
really kind of neat to think about
now again that was just using the
standard linear proper orthogonal
decomposition
you might be able to get better
representations with these deep
autoencoders
people are working on it this is an
active area of research
okay so maybe as i conclude i'll just
give you kind of this
this you know slightly light-hearted
example so this is one of my favorite
um images is this this painting um
la primavera by archimbaldo and i
believe this is a painting of emperor
rudolph ii
where he would essentially represent
famous people as flowers or vegetables
or fruits
and this was all done in archimbaldo's
imagination this was hundreds of years
ago
but it's a lot like the modern deep
dreams that we see now that are so
popular
today and so this is a really cool image
visualization where someone has taken
uh archimbaldo's essentially deep dream
and they have repainted
it with other features like peacock
feathers or dogs or cats
and so i think this is really kind of
meta that it's a deep dream
of one of the original deep dreams but
this begs the question
if i have a flow field again like my
reynolds number 100 cylinder flow
can i do a deep dream can i paint this
with the texture of a turbulent flow
or of starry night right can i take a
simple flow that's easy to characterize
easy to model easy to control and can i
in a physically relevant way
paint it so that it looks like a much
more turbulent uh or complex flow field
okay so uh lots of interesting stuff
again this is the tip of the iceberg but
if you can treat your fluid flow
like an image sequence you can leverage
tons of powerful techniques for machine
learning
and again i think we're only scratching
the the surface of what can be done here
there's tons more to do
uh read more about it get into it it's
going to be a super exciting
field for decades to come all right
thank you